wir sind ja von den höchstständen aus
dem märz noch etwas entfernte aber man
hat das gefühl wir sind auf dem weg
wieder dorthin zu den höchstwerten aus
dem märz oder vielleicht sogar darüber
hinaus wenn wir uns einmal nämlich die
shop zahl der kanzlerin anschauen 19.200
neuinfektionen pro tag ende dezember
hatte sie vorher gesagt als worst case
szenario wenn wir jetzt aber mal die
realität mit ihrem szenario
gegenüberstellen und die beiden
szenarien gegenüber legen dann fällt
einem auf dass der anstieg in der
realität schon stärker ist als der
anstieg angenommen ist bei der kanzlerin
ja das ist leider so und dementsprechend
wenn wir nichts tun und wenn ich stelle
was passiert wenn wir diese magischen
19.000 relativ früh erreichen und das
ist wäre dann tatsächlich eine zweite
welle
natürlich kann man die die die wellen in
anführungszeichen nicht vergleichen also
das was wir im frühjahr erlebt haben war
ein sehr dramatischer sehr schneller
anstieg der gefolgt wurde von der
intensiven maßnahmen sehr restriktiven
maßnahmen jetzt haben wir einen
langsameren anstieg der natürlich auch
sich bedrohlich auswirken kann und wir
halten im augenblick mit dem wissen was
wir erworben haben mit der gezielten
maßnahmen gegen den ausbruch insofern
bin ich im augenblick tatsächlich noch
optimistisch dass wir das was wir jetzt
von frau merkel prognostiziert haben was
uns möglicherweise droht doch nicht
erreichen werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren